myope mi animal le loup-garou peuple les
romans les comics les clips de Michael
Jackson les films et les forêts sombres
les experts batailles sur l'origine de
la légende mais si un médecin pouvait
examiner un loup-garou sans danger
j'aurais un loup-garou vegan par exemple
il lui diagnostic reste sans doute une
hypertricose doublée
c'est un développement excessif des
poils ça peut ressembler à ça mais ça
peut aller un peu plus loin voir
beaucoup plus loin pour le comportement
maintenant la lycanthropie clinique
c'est tout simplement une maladie
psychiatrique qui consiste à se prendre
pour un loup marché à quatre pattes
pousser des hurlements et mordre et pour
la pleine lune ça c'est juste du
folklore par contre